نعم ، هناك شيء آخر أعلم أنه
سيضعني في ورطة
ولكنك تعلم أننا جميعًا رأينا
ما يحدث في العالم في
الوقت الحالي مع أوكرانيا ولا أحد
سعيد بما يحدث ولا ينبغي لأحد
أن يقبل أي قتل  في
العالم أي اضطهاد أه
لكن أه نحن جميعًا لم
يُسمح لنا أبدًا بالتحدث عن السياسة في
الرياضة ولكن فجأة أصبح
مسموحًا بذلك ، أه أننا سمح لنا آمل
أن ينظر الناس أيضًا إلى
القمع في كل مكان في العالم
أعني أن الفلسطينيين
مروا بذلك على مدى الـ 74 عامًا الماضية
واه واه
لكني أعتقد ولكن أعتقد أنه
لا يتناسب مع رواية
وسائل الإعلام في الغرب أه لم نتمكن من  أه نتحدث
عن ذلك ولكن الآن بعد أن نتحدث
عن أوكرانيا يمكننا التحدث عن
الفلسطينيين ، لذا يرجى وضع ذلك في الاعتبار ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك.